welcome to Hannity we have big breaking
news tonight a multiple fronts a former
top prosecutor from Ukraine has now
implicated
yes sleepy creepy crazy uncle Joe in
what is a very serious crime we have
brand-new evidence including a signed
affidavit signed under the threat of
perjury the real charge of perjury if in
fact he lied Rudy Giuliani's
comprehensive timeline coming up tonight
and it is very revealing also this
important news and information will
prove that the media mob has been and
continues to be covering for Joe Biden
and his son also the fraudulent Pelosi
Schiff impeachment circus is getting off
to a horrific start their first star
witness
just literally shot down and deflated
all of the left's anti-trump impeachment
fantasies and by the way the Cowardly
Adam shift has been caught in yet
another disgusting lie there are now
growing calls for the liar in chief the
cowardly shifty shift to be kicked off
his committee also now buckle up is
going to be a brand new deep state leak
this is a warning pretty much a
minute-by-minute a new non whistleblower
whistleblower every second because they
think all we got traction here let's
what's a China CNN of Russia two moments
ago fake news CNN reporting about
another leak from another phone call
with another world leader this time the
president of China the corrupt media is
now trying to flood the zone with the
anti-trump speculation especially since
Ukraine is blowing up in their faces and
again backfiring now the president said
this to China was gonna say this to
Russia this to the Saudis they're gonna
now demand every transcript ever of
every conversation our president has as
commander in chief of the foreign leader
all right well let's play this game I
would like the release of every Biden
Ukraine phone call transcript and by the
way while we're at it I would like every
Obama Iran mullah
rouhani a transcript I'd like the obama
putin transcripts what is the
flexibility that he showed after his
reelection you get the point it's all a
fishing expedition
you know first we have to pass health
care to see what's in it well
peach Donald Trump and then manufacture
a reason later we'll have more on this
in a moment but first we do start with
the rampant dishonesty in the Democratic
Party and their close friends allies
tied at the hip the media mob tonight
it's almost like the invasion of the
body snatchers remember that movie they
look like us but they don't think like
anything that we recognize devoid of any
real perception I don't even know at
this point if the left knows or can see
their own hypocrisy that is glaring I
don't know if it's just raw
unadulterated sewer swamp politics that
drives them or a quest to regain power
that's certainly a part of it or they're
blind psychotic rage against the
president but what I do know is that
liberals are constantly we know they
already look down a we conservatives the
people you see it when they call us
smelly Walmart people guilty
irredeemable deplorable that like Donald
Trump whereas Obama once said you know
those angry Americans that cling to
their God I cling guns Second Amendment
Bibles and religion yeah we all need God
in our lives or New York Governor Cuomo
revealing those conservatives that are
pro-life and prosecute amend they're not
New Yorkers memories are that and nobody
needs ten bullets to kill ADEA okay he
doesn't believe in the Second Amendment
either and once during his embarrassing
five minute audition to be a radio host
remember an emotional Alec Baldwin got
angry that me and the great one Mark
Levin called in and tag-team him and he
called me of ignorant former
construction work hacked from Long
Island guilty of that too I am very
proud of my two decades long blue-collar
hard-working history yeah my mom was a
prison guard her work 16-hour shifts for
twenty five years the point is these
people have so much disdain for honest
hardworking Americans with just a
different political opinion okay I like
to shop at Walmart Costco Target you
name it yeah those are the people that
make America great again and then we pay
these jackasses in Washington salaries
and pay for their health care plans
remember that a better than the
Obamacare exchanges we're stuck with by
a long shot
and these Democrats have now lost all
perspective for example let's look at
creepy Uncle Joe's Ukrainian scandal
play a game tonight here's the game
let's replace the name VP Joe Biden and
we'll say VP Donald Trump I know we
won't like the well the reduction in
title but just play along and replace
the name of hunter Biden will call
hunter Biden Don jr. what do you think
would happen is the name of the game
what if Don jr. were taking millions of
dollars from what is a shady Ukrainian
oil giant billions of dollars from China
while his father was vice president and
let's say it's Don Jr who had zero
experience with either country or any of
the businesses energy oil glass gas
private equity that were paying in these
huge amounts of money
what if vice president Donald Trump
leveraged a billion US tax dollars to
get a Ukrainian prosecutor fired who was
investigating Donald juniors company
what do you think the media mob would be
calling this you think it's a it's a
conspiracy theory or a hoax you think
what do you think they'd be endless
breathless hysterical reporting for
weeks on end
what if political reported that an RNC
operative and contractor was working
hand-in-hand with Ukrainian government
digging up dirt on Hillary Clinton for
the 2016 election and they were
successful what at that same article
read Ukrainian efforts to sabotage
Hillary backfire
what would the media mob react reaction
be to that report what about the
Grassley and Senator Johnson letter
about the quote brazen efforts by the
DNC to use the government of Ukraine for
the express purpose of finding negative
information on Hillary Clinton what if
the letter was about the RNC and what
about Hillary Clinton's dirty Russian
dossier what if it was Donald Trump who
funneled money through a law firm
campaign finance violation to then hire
a not research group fusion GPS to hire
an ex foreign spy to dig up Russian dirt
on Hillary Clinton probably knowingly
from the beginning
Russian misinformation and
disinformation oh come to think of it
Donald Trump had a server private server
legally had top-secret classified
material on it
and what if Donald Trump deleted 33,000
emails that were subpoenaed and then
destroyed his cellphones and then bleach
bit the hard drive you think the media
mob would care now I say all this
because it's not funny because this is
how sick frankly is cancerous what this
mob in the media is doing to this
country every day this also applies to
the current Ukrainian witch-hunt against
President Trump and as you know
Democrats and the mob and the media they
give it of course the white glove
treatment to the fake whistleblower was
not a whistleblower it's not first-hand
information it's hearsay from the Intel
community then you got the guy running
it the cowardly Adam shifty ship in his
office even giving this fake
whistleblower advice on how to prepare
the critical complaint and get the given
the advice to get a lawyer and the media
mobs praise this person over and over
again but thank goodness we have
videotape I was actually on the air
during the Clinton impeachment
I know I've now started my 24th year at
Fox a long time but in the 90s when a
woman named Linda Tripp remember she was
a whistleblower against then President
Bill Clinton well the median mob well
treated this whistleblower a lot
differently and I think it's worth
taking a trip down memory lane
take a look friendship means different
things to different people but few
people expect to have their friendship
betrayed by having their private
conversations tape as Linda Tripp did to
Monica Lewinsky I cannot believe that
someone who professes to be a friend
could go about scheming the way that she
did and absolutely defying and violating
Monica the way that she did co-workers
often viewed her as an inveterate
busybody that has she always been a
snoop and a gossip with a particular
interest in other people's romantic
lives she is somebody who's had a
pattern of interest in other people's
marital lives this story of Linda trips
betrayal is really very unappealing and
she comes off as a conniving and really
not a likable person conniving no like
person imagine the media mob treating
the current so called non whistleblower
whistleblower like that but also
breaking tonight we are learning
this non whistleblower whistleblower who
followed a complaint on president
Trump's phone call with Ukraine oh yeah
registered drunk Democrat just like
apparently the lawyer she hired and we
also know that he or she have no direct
knowledge of the phone calls zero
nothing and the complaint was entirely
based on hearsay which would not be
admissible in a court of law just the
fact and media reports and by the way
that the office of the shifty the
Cowardly shift will spoke directly with
this person encourage that person to get
a lawyer and filed all the filed a
report with the inspector general but
that didn't stop the Cowardly Adam
Schiff from going to on MSDN see that
would be area 51
Roswell Rachel Maddow's conspiracy
channel and the DNC Network this
September again lying through his teeth
he said quote we have not spoken
directly with the whistleblower it's
hardly the first time by the way Schiff
has been caught in a lie is the biggest
liar in Congress he once said he had
direct evidence he said at numerous time
direct evidence of Trump Russia
collusion the evidence of collusion was
in plain sight we're still looking for
it cowardly shift come on the program
bring it with you and more recently in a
committee hearing well he performed a
dramatic reading because he didn't get
what he wanted it in a transcript of the
phone call with the president Ukrainian
president Solinsky anyway from that
transcript he had to completely
fabricate it because it wasn't what he
wanted it to be so he just made it up
called it a parody later someone might
want to tell speaker Pelosi also her
partner in crime is a serial liar
because she seems totally unaware of his
lies take a look I know you support the
chairmanship but wasn't right for him to
have that dramatic interpretation of the
president's transferred the phone call
at the hearing last week I want the
American people to know what that phone
call was about I want them to hear it
so yeah it's fair it
but it's using the president's own words
so if he's well those weren't the
president's words whose an
interpretation of the president's words
you're saying he made this up it did not
make it up whoopsie-daisy one of Lucy's
brilliant staffers might want to help
her get on a computer so she can see
what the Cowardly Adam shifty [ __ ] is up
to by the way you might want to tell her
a mile from her house is a big huge drug
problem where people are defecating and
urinating in the streets not in her
exact neighborhood but one mile away
Pelosi also needs to answer some
important questions about a fraudulent
impeachment inquiry in a letter to the
speaker Minority Leader McCarthy is
demanding rightfully so answers to the
following procedures required in any
official impeachment process quote do
you intend to grant co-equal subpoena
power to both the chair and the ranking
member at the committee level do you
intend to require that all subpoenas be
subject to a vote of the full committee
at the request of either the chair or
the ranking member do you intend to
provide the president's counsel the
right to attend all hearings and
depositions do you intend to provide the
president's counsel the right to present
evidence do you intend to provide the
president's counsel the right to object
to the admittance of evidence and do you
intend to provide the president's
counsel the right to recommend a witness
list and finally do you intend to refer
all findings on impeachment to chairman
Nadler on the Judiciary Committee as
prescribed in rule 10 I assume of the
rules of the house or his chairmanship
in charge of leading this inquiry as has
been reported in the press the
aforementioned questions of standard
operating procedures ready impeachment
proceeding anything less is a sham by
the way three times we've had
impeachment yet the house would usually
vote on the inquiry she's not wanting
that to happen because if they do all
those things Kevin McCarthy is asking
for would in fact follow now tomorrow
the White House will send a similar
letter daring Pelosi to get serious
about our which up let's put them all on
the record I say call the roll so time
will tell is the speaker a name only
serious about impeachment or is this a
big huge political stunt that's just out
to hurt the country and divide the
country further whatever art ruined
Jen's Pelosi's impeachment charade is
getting off to a horrific start how do
we know because breaking tonight and
we'll have first-hand well
information coming up the very first
star witness in the proceeding the US
special envoy to Ukraine
Kurt Volker reportedly and I've heard
from people in the room devastated and
destroyed the Democrats Ukrainian
conspiracy theories all of them by the
way to mr. Volker congratulations I hear
big day coming up and this comes on the
heels of another major disappointment
for Democrats this week far-left members
of Congress were absolutely giddy with
anticipation over an urgent State
Department briefing about Ukraine yeah
it turned out the State Department's
nonpartisan inspector general presented
them with evidence of DNC collusion with
Ukraine and a timeline of Biden's
shakedown of the Ukrainian prosecutor
and Democrats and the media mob well are
the evidence a disproven conspiracy
theory because it's blowing up right in
your face and you're helping Donald
Trump in the process because we have a
devastating timeline that's put put
together by former New York City Mayor
Rudy Giuliani it was on last night this
paints a much different picture keep in
mind this time frame
Giuliani began his investigation into
Biden and Ukraine well before Biden ever
announced his intention to run for
president in 2018 as president Trump's
attorney the conducting employee was
conducting important research why
because he was still defending his
client the president from the lying
spurious allegations against robert
muller and his witch hunt and for
although willfully ignorant members of
the mob who are shielding joe biden
tonight you may want to pay close
attention to this timeline i'll try and
read it slowly to you it starts in 2010
mykola Zola chef ski the oligarch and
the pro-russian Ukrainian government of
Viktor Yankovic started granting his
company valuable gas exploration permits
the core company that's called burry
smih holdings
let's flash forward to the February of
2014
President Obama names Vice President
sleepy creepy Uncle Joe as the point man
for Ukraine in the same month president
Yankovic is ousted and Yankovic and
solove Chesky and the oligarch behind
the barista Holdings issue they flee to
Russia and in April of 2014
sole of cesky places hunter Biden and
Devin Archer and his partner and former
aide to then Secretary of State John
Kerry on the board of burry smih neither
person in any experience that we can
find an oil gas energy none of them any
experience we can find on Ukraine but
they were paid millions of dollars for
their expertise and what I don't know
expertise of knowing Joe Biden I guess
in August of 2014 Ukraine's prosecutor
this is General Victor Shokan he opened
a criminal investigation into barrese mo
Holdings that is a fact and hunter Biden
and Devin Archer identified as persons
of interest in the investigation by the
way people under investigation are
notified in January of 2015
baristas Olaf Chesky is named a fugitive
by Ukraine's government hunter Biden
remains on board barrese mo Holdings May
of 2015 hunter Biden meets with the
Deputy Secretary of State Tony blinken
regarding concerns about Purisima
holdings in October of 2015 Hillary
Clinton allegedly tells Vice President
Biden she will not go after hunter Biden
if he runs but can't control what her
staff will do meaning I'll leak it in
December 2015 VP Biden tells the
president of Ukraine that he must
dismiss the prosecutor general viktor
Shokan after the New York Times gave him
a heads up his sons being investigated
and in February 2016 that's Vice
President Biden and ukrainian president
talking on the phone about removing the
prosecutor general i'd love by the way
can we please release this transcript
who's investigating his son and then a
march of 2016
Biden then vice president issues is now
infamous quid pro quo in other words the
shakedown that he was going to withhold
a billion of your hard-earned tax
dollars and loan guarantees unless that
prosecutor general Shokan is fired few
days later Shokan was fired and Biden
bragged about it and in May a new
prosecutor general is higher
that very same spring the new prosecutor
meets with the American ambassador she
allegedly tells him to drop several
investigations and meanwhile in June the
Ukrainian law enforcement agency
announces it has uncovered a massive
fraud scheme involving that's right
hunter Biden's partner Purisima Holdings
that's a month biden meets with
ukrainian prime minister few months
later in november ukraine announced that
the case around the briefs was close
it's just like that democrats and the
media mob they say oh there's no
evidence there's no evidence it's a
conspiracy theory really no evidence
why was hunter Biden on the board of
parisa what was his qualifications
certainly wasn't his expertise in the
energy sector or the country of Ukraine
and clearly Biden knows about his sons
lucrative business deals in spite of his
public comments and by the way here he's
pictured on a gold course oh that's in
the summer of 2014 might be some banach
somebody speculated and fellow briefs of
a board member Devin Archer believe it
or not hunter had an even more lucrative
deal with the Bank of China from Russia
to Ukraine the left has been smearing
President Trump with one lie one
besmirched meant one conspiracy theory
one hoax after another but tonight their
sick twisted scheming is about to
boomerang and blow up again just like
Russia Russia right in their face and by
the way creepy sleepy Joe 303 303 as
trouble tonight and so is his son the US
government is not his family piggy bank
in spite of what he arrogantly thought